tonight on PE Morgan uncensored Israel
at War the uncensored debate Muhammad
hijab is a Muslim philosopher scholar
and YouTuber whose first appearance on
the show was viewed by more than 8
million people Rabbi schmi boak has been
called the most famous Rabbi in America
is the international bestselling author
of kosher hate and the Israel Warrior
both men are passionate both men are
influential and they both have
vehemently opposing views tonight they
go uncensored and head-to-head we're
bringing together two very opinionated
passionate influential people very
opposing views and we're going to have a
proper debate and we're going to see if
somewhere there is perhaps more that we
can agree on than we first imagined so
thank you for joining me Gentlemen We
tossed a coin before we came on air
tonight and actually you won the the
toss um and you said you want to go
second ier my my brother and the way
this will work U Muhammed we have four
sections of this debate and at the start
of each one you'll both get one minute
uninterrupted to say what you want to
say about each of the themed uh titles
of each block so you go first and at the
end of your minute you'll hear a sound
and when you hear that uh you end and
then a rabbi sh gets his chance to speak
so the First theme is a simple one are
Hamas to blame you have a minute
Muhammad from now from one perspective
Hamas started the battle because
obviously from October 7th even they
themselves titled it
AA or the flooding OFA but from another
perspective if you look at from an
international law perspective we're
talking about 1967 we're talking about
resolution security resolution 242 in
which it is actually stated that um
Israel is in a belligerent State because
they're occupying the West Bank East
Jerusalem and Gaza and they have been so
therefore the war has been continual for
a very long time according to
international law but let's remove Hamas
from the situation Al together let's
remove them what do you have you have
the West Bank and what do you have in
the West Bank you have 187 children who
have been put in prisons they have been
put in prisons according to bet Salam
without charge you have 44 children
before October the 7th that have been
killed before October the 7th in just
2023 alone so if you remove Hamas
equation what you have you have the West
Bank you you remove dominance from the
equation you have the West Bank and what
do you have you have occupation you have
settlement which you condemned
rightfully so you condemned that on your
show the settlement is there okay R
respon resolution 242 in the UN doesn't
mention a single thing about aggress
aggression or aggressor that is a total
fabrication and it speaks about disputed
territories but let's be clear the
occupier of Gaza is Kamas they won an
election in 2006 had a civil war with
Mahmud Abbas took the Palestinian
Authority officials threw them off
buildings killed Muslims killed Arabs
Mahmud Abbas is afraid to go to Gaz he's
terrified of Kamas he hasn't been there
since 2007 and let's be clear Hamas is
an abomination to Islam sulan Salah
Aladin the greatest Muslim conqueror of
all time after whom the main artery in
in gaza's named he said that you have to
allow all prisoners to be redeemed he
would never hold hostages this is and
remember the Islam is about fair
treatment of prisoners of War Hamas
beheaded Thai non-jewish workers you
asked your last appearance Here For Real
uh firsthand sources I'm the firstand
source I saw it in kib Salim they raped
women they had sex with dead women's
body they are evil and do the right
thing and call them Evil all right we've
had a minute each okay we've got a
passionate start Muhammad let me ask you
about Hamas I want to first before you
do that I want to commend you P honestly
because bringing me on for the second
time I have to commend you and the fact
that you actually condemned the
settlements is very good but people want
to know do you think the idea are a
terrorist organization uh no you don't
think they ter okay well if you look at
the UN definition of terrorist
organization they say killing civilians
for political ask my opinion no defition
ACC to your end definition is killing
civilians for political objectives why
are they not terrorist organiz well well
you've asked me a straight question I
don't think they are Terror organization
so when you see babies like this the
ones who the ones who kill babies like
this are not terrorists it's horrific so
the people who kill babies are not
terrorists well let me let me respond
let me respond both you can both get
into this here's my response to that and
I thought carefully about this I'd be
very honest about my own feelings I have
a real moral quandry about this because
as a father I I hate these scenes of
kids being killed in Gaza it's horrific
right we all know it's horrific are they
a terrist organization though I'm I'm
about to explain to you what I think my
position is my position is after what
happened on October the 7th it was so
barbaric so disgusting so you can kill
children well no what you can do that's
exactly what teror say by let me this is
not this is someone else becoming the
host of the show now interviewing you
being
interv you and I are being you're not
here to interview him have your put make
lose control of his own show you do this
all the time it will not I'm not going
to let it happen tonight let me ask have
respect for stop interviewing the
interviewer and be respect and resp tell
me is it terrist Organization no why not
I do not believe so they kill civilians
for political let me answer go ahead
okay here's my answer to that when Hamas
did what they did two things one Hamas
knew exactly what Israel's response
would be they knew they would come
incredibly hard I don't absolve them
wait a minute I'm olving anybody I'm not
I'm not absolving them okay I'm saying
the West Bank is where's H where Ham let
me you have to let me answer you
children killed like this West this is
this is this is ridiculous wait a minute
R let me just ask you quickly go ahead I
believe Israel has a right to defend
itself from after that Terror can they
kill children wait a minute can they
wait a minute particularly after the
Hamas spokesman only last week said if
they want to do this again and again and
again that's an existential threat to
Israel why don't they fight man man
children wae let me mhamad let me answer
you a ratio of 100 to1 by the way let me
answer you 100 to1 ratio me answer you
otherwise it's pointless go ahead so I
agree that Israel must defend itself I
agree they have to get rid of Hamas
because Hamas is wedded to an ideology
of existentially removing is this
acceptable wait a minute I'm coming to
your answer I'm coming to your answer
this is not this is not wait this is not
even this is not even a conversation Len
I came the way fromat debate and he will
not let anyone else speak if that's how
these shows work no no no you are rude
you are bully you just are trying to
interrupt people I'm going to have a
chance to speak or there's no point in
doing this show he did this last time
and you allowed him to but I won't allow
him to I will never be bullied by a
bully let me let me be clear no one wait
a minute no one's allowing me to answer
your question and it's this I believe
Israel has a right to defend itself I
agree that they need to get rid of Hamas
who are terror group this way well
here's the quantry for me morally right
why is a quantry though I tell you why
with Hamas is not a quantry why because
in war in war when you decare War as
Britain did with the Nazis 100 to1 ratio
no no there are combat a far higher
number of children in Gaza proportionate
to population than almost anywhere in
the world so when they go after a chance
very
sadly let me
finish you have do you are the one who
insisted on equal time I never did but
you will not respect I will come to you
literally 30 seconds he's going to ask
you question 30 seconds I'll come to you
he's going to come to you after let me
finish please I charge Muhammad so my
final point on this is unfortunately in
war civilians ratio 100 to1 ratio yes
to1 ratio yes they get killed no no not
100 to1 ratio it's an unable ra get
killed list in you come you know you
know Pi can I say respectfully and I
mean this is no insult I'm amazed that
you're intimidated by this man I feel I
feel well with all du respect
I can speak speak if I can speak I
wouldn't bring back if I can speak if I
can
speak no no he does not because I have I
have before he did this debate he went
on X on Twitter and said I'm only doing
it if there's equal time and then he is
violating that I never ask for equal
time I just want to be heard but he
won't even let me be heard let me
explain something to you you said in a
in a video the other day and you can
look me in the eye you said that Jews
are now trembling Muhammad I am no no no
don't interrupt me I am not trembling
it's all on my it's all my Instagram
page now you see this yamaka it means
that I represent something I'm an
ambassador you're an ambassador of Islam
you are talking about a religion that
started the world's first universities
educated women Fatima started the first
Fe Fierce University in the in the n9th
century in Fez Morocco irant now we have
a man who says that he's a
representative of speak go he goes to
speaker corner he speaks about whether
5-year-old girls are old enough for sex
he says that game men are dying of AIDS
as a as a punishment from God and I'm
sorry have to say this to to the
listeners that blood is gushing from
their backsides they're better off the
you know what it is because you are
desecrating a great religion now let me
tell you why let me tell you why it
appeal why why it's here because he will
defend bring back to topic he will
defend Butchery run savager he doesn't
care thatas is is an Abomination to
Islam because running away because Islam
the children in Gaza are dying because
Hamas uses them as bulletproof vest the
United States and France and England
said yesterday that the alifa hospital
is a military based it has a tiny veneer
it has a tiny vene of of emergency rooms
minut but the underneath all of it is a
military base and let me tell you
something if it's true that any of these
countries care about the Muslims in Gaza
because they believe what he's saying
that Israel killing them this is a map
of all the countries that took place
last week in in Riyad to save the
Palestinians of Gaza from Israel do you
know how many that's Israel a tiny thing
you know how many of them took in even
one Palestinian from Gaza zero nothing
look at that map because they want the
Arabs want to
see the Arabs want to
see don't intimidate me don't bully me
don't intimidate me I've got to be to
ask questions it's a
debate let me let me ask you one
specific question which he raised which
I don't think actually is your belief I
don't think you have defended what Hamas
did on October the 7th yeah haven't I
think you
share
unless are they
evil are they
evil now doing what you accused him of
doing let me ask you what is your view
of her Mass post October 7th I think
that they just like anybody else have to
be examined have to have to look at all
what's your opinion about them yeah I
think that if look here's my opinion let
me be straightforward about this right
anybody who kills civilians anybody
whether it's the IDF I'm consistent in
this manner if if it's proven with
Beyond reasonable doubt that these
people have killed civilians in both of
our faith traditions in Islam and
Judaism in the Quran is mentioned in the
prophet he said it himself you cannot
kill a woman you cannot kill a child I
condemn them I condemn them that's what
I do straight away whether is Muslim
whether he non-muslim whether he
Christian or anybody else I've already
said that so I'm not being inconsistent
here my question is if that is exactly
the barometer that we're using if that's
the moral reasoning that we're using
then we have to say look if you have a
100 to1 ratio and that's what it is 100
to1 ratio and you know how I got this
figure I got this figure from the IDF
themselves because they have reported
okay let me ask you this let me ask you
this does Hamas deserve to stay in power
after what they did I don't think we
should have Hamas in power what I think
we should let me tell you we should we
should have a we should have a
Palestinian Authority with bigger armies
and airports with proper tanks and with
aanes like every country in world you
know what you might be right absolutely
they allow it how you get rid ofas what
you don't do I can tell you for a fact
is try and kill three thou 30,000 of
them with 100 to1 ratio because if you
do that then you're committing genocide
CU you'd have to kill 3 million
Palestinians do you know even do you
even know the definition of genocide I
haven't said genocide what you just said
it I I what is the definition of
genocide what the you always claim to be
an academic you're always your cral what
is the
definition
genocide you'll be genoci genocide is
where I Target you target an ethnicity
for extinction Geno ethnicity side
murder yes if you do million you
genoci
Mil there are 1.8 million
Muslim live in total peace in Israel as
equal citizens in fact Israel practiced
reverse discrimination against the Jews
cuz the Jews are conscripted to fight
Hamas so if Israel excuse me no you will
not interrupt me if Israel you will not
interrupt me you will not interrupt me
you will not interrupt you will not
bully me you will not interrupt me I am
not afraid of you stop saying je tremble
now let me let me be clear shout over
each other well then let then you need
to control your guest with all due
respect okay contr he said equal time
and there's no equal time now there's no
equal time if Israel was interested in a
genocide of the Palestinians why do they
have 1.8 million equal Arab Muslim
citizens who are in the Israeli Supreme
Court who are one-third of the medical
profession do you know do you know do
you know that an arabe an Arab judge put
the president of Israel in jail for
accused rape that was mosha katab That's
how little Israel is an apartheid state
genocidal State this man sitting next to
me Muhammad hijab will not distinguish
between self-defense when Hamas comes to
brutalize and murder your people versus
when an army like like France stops re
retali simply
protect you don't believe the Jews
should have a right to defend say it all
right then then say it Jews have the
right to defend themselves yes they do
that's why everybody has a right to
defend themselves
to they can go to God but no they can go
in but don't no hey hold on let me tell
you my position let me tell you my so
they can go in thank God he asked me a
question answer it yes they can go into
even fight even the general of Hamas he
said Arabic we are waiting for you
that's why he's being say hold on you've
asked me a question go ahead they do
have a right my advoc what I've been
advocating all along is face Toof face
confrontation what I'm against hold on
excuse me what I'm against is a 100 to1
ratio because if you
have FAS is hiding under hospitals what
face to face confrontation Kamas is sh
children I'm okay with face to face
confrontation I like it block two is
it's the honorable way block two is
exactly this question my only
observation so far you're being more
personal and AD homenum than he is with
all the respect I think that's extremely
unfair because every time I say anything
no listen you you keep answering for him
when when you actually ask him questions
he if mam Mam's job wants to be a
representative and ambassador of Islam
then he has to take responsibility for
his position he actually said that Islam
believes in death we we are you're not
going to beat us cuz we want to die
we're prepared to lose
thousands merely religion of death you
are poor ambassador of you believe in
martyrdom of you want to be a martyr
yeah absolutely you want to die fighting
the Jews I didn't say Jews who said
Jews means told
us whoever dies defending themselves
defending their wealth no are you do you
want to die defending Islam but do you
want
isace hold this child for us is a m
you're right do you agree or not age or
not Hamas is using him as a human shield
he is yes is hiding behind him to next
all right let's time out come on man
this my time TR trying to talk over each
other because the viewers can't hear it
right I don't mind the passion I don't
mind the debate I don't mind the fire I
do you mind if we can't hear what you're
saying it's pointless let's do the
minute let's go to the second the second
topic right this time minute RAB SMY you
will go first with a minute to say what
you want to say and then Muhammad you'll
get yours so the theme is this and the
question is this for Block two has
Israel gone too far in its response to
the October the 7th Terror attacks okay
Rob you have a minute starting now I
just came here by taxi and passed the
statue of Winston Churchill that's in
the lifetime of our parents okay he is
the greatest British Statesman of the
20th century you know what he did when
he had a genocidal threat knowing that
Hitler wanted to eviscerate annihilate
Britain he carpet bombed all of Germany
Dresden Essen um uh Hamburg Israel has
not even gotten close to that Israel
does not send its Air Force to carpet
bomb C he it sends in its military I
have a friend who died six six children
39 because he was personally trying to
stop at Kamas Terror tunnel Israel is
surgical Israel is only going after the
fighters Israel has open humanitarian
corridors for the for the Palestinians
to go south Hamas shoots them and make
sure they don't go Hamas builds its
military structures right shifa hospital
is this much hospital and it's this much
military they love using Palestinians
and that's why they've stolen their
money they got they got about $16
billion from the International Community
there isn't one bomb shelter in in Gaza
they don't care about civilians at all
Israel is doing the right thing you have
a minute what I'm saying is the 100 100
to1 ratio comes from the following
figures we know that 10,000 civilians
have died of them according to the IDF
as reported by the guardian 60 dozens
they say about 60 uh Hamas died which
we're being liberal by saying 100 to1
figures for everyone ham M you have to
kill a 100 civilians that's effectively
what we're saying if the trajectory
continues as it is if the trajectory
continues as it is then you have to kill
3 million Palestinian civilians in order
to kill 30,000 Hamas Fighters if you
want to ex extinguish them eviscerate
them annihilate them destroy them you
have to do that now you have Herzog who
is the president that you you
interviewed saying that all Palestinians
they are responsible this man is being
more slippery he's being more slippery
than the lubricants that he sells in his
daughter's sex shop and that's the
reality of the situation did you really
just say that you know you seem obsessed
with Jewish sex it's bizarre yesterday
you actually spoke about Ben Shapiro's
wife you actually you said to Ben
chapiro your wife's a carrot you're more
of a man is that what you're trying to
say then you said that Jews have pdsm
you're speaking about sexual lubricants
while people are dying you know Muhammad
get your head out of the Jewish bedroom
it's really bizarre get let me be clear
sexual lubricants how dildos get can we
get it back you speak about 5-year-old
girls being
ready go back let's go back to the isue
go back to the issue let me ask a
question why are you shaking I've got on
your come on let's it's a serious I
think he's got one of his daughters VI
come leave it
please cut cut all this stuff out so
is's that point why why leave what he
represents Point abusing each other
personally
I want to stick to the debate get to
theate you don't want to do it we'll end
the debate let's get to the debate let
me let me ask Muhammad a question right
I don't disagree with you that so far it
seems to me yes obviously a fact that
many many more Palestinian civilians
innocent people are getting killed as
retribution by the Israelis for what
happened October 7th that's indisputable
right their argument is that they're
going after a terror organization Hamas
and unfortunately in war as rabbii
correct said about what Churchill did in
World War II church was wrong church was
wrong war criminal yes he was yes he he
was church is war the
brial Geor all
criminals war criminal let me get you
think you think Winston Churchill was a
war criminal in standing up to The Naz
by killing the who killed 12 million
people I Believe by doing what he did
was a war criminal by killing in Hamburg
by indiscriminate killing Collective
punishment my morality says that's
impossible okay that means the British
people who supported him Ved they just
second the British people you believe he
a war criminal yes so so therefore you
your belief is that no retaliatory
action by retaliate to the man not to
the babies tell me a war in history yes
where civilians haven't been killed no
I'm not saying civilians haven't been
killed it's Rao ratio it's the ra
AC RAB so let me give you a ratio how
many people do the na killed I don't
know you don't we we know they killed
six million they killed 12 million
people incling six million Jews right so
how many died in how many died in dresda
how many civilians died in Germany do
you know I don't know exactly right so
you don't actually know what you're
talking about I do know what I'm talking
about because I know Hamburg you said
it's about you if I'm wrong yeah go
ahead if I'm wrong you said it's to do
with the raos R you don't know the
ratios when Forst
Church a minute RAB when you call winst
Churchill a criminal basing on ratios
you don't even know what they are no I
know no we there's difference of opinion
among the the scholars no there isn't
there is different tell us the opinion
what are they tell us tell us what they
are hold on there's of how many excuse
me stop speaking for how many am I
speaking how many in Dres whatever the
number you don't indiscriminant I'm
against it no he
doesn't dr's about 2500 ,000 and uh at
the time the the Germans were saying
250,000 we know it's about 25,000 today
let me be let me be clear Winston
Churchill was the greatest Statesman of
the 20th century he saved the world from
I agree Nazi Terror that you could live
in a country that is only around today
because of The Bravery that man showing
no gratitude is the height of
top sck on topic call all the
British the na defeated the Nazis on
topic stop interrupting meated
criminals his parents all the other
people
criminals wrong no no let me let me be
clear let me interrupt each let clear
Muhammad hijab trades in falsehoods 300
to1 what are you talking about and now
he says that now he says the Jews are
about to kill 3 million say the fact
that this man considers himself an
Oxford academic I was the rabbi at
Oxford University for 11 years this is a
travesty this is a Travy graduate from
any Unity did you graduate from any un I
have a rebal graduate let me
answer me I ex communic
am can speak this is pointless Rabbi
smoy is there a limit to the number of
civilians in Gaza that Israel can kill
to try and eliminate Hamas that's a
great question there is thank you but
let me ask you not even one not one
beautiful Palestinian child should have
to die because Hamas kicked out M that
was my question and yeah and not one
should have to die what what what the
answer to your question is that Hamas if
they surrender unconditionally then okay
fine then let them let them allow all
the civilian Israel said that all the
civilians can leave all the civilians
should go south they beg them and that's
something that militaries never do
Church did not tell the people and J
come on and and you see you can't you
came with all your notes I'm not here we
get the point M this is this is all this
is this is all proof that he can't
debate he has to use these images debate
me we ask you to come on with all your
ex SM let me ask you a question a member
of the uh cabinet in Israel was actually
quoted as saying that nuclear weapons
were an option that Israel could use a
no one's ever confirmed Israel has
nuclear weapons it's long being
suspected that seemed pretty clear
confirmation why why you against nuclear
weapons if against res why against let
me ask the question let me ask but why
are you against it I've done this before
this job let me do it okay so when that
guy says that if you're if you're living
as an innocent civilian in in Gaza what
the hell are you thinking that an
Israeli government member threatens the
use of a nuclear weapon which would
obliterate pretty much all of Gaza and
everyone in it thank you for the
question if that were true why hasn't
Israel used nuclear weapons against
Naser when he invaded hold on hold on
and the and the answer and the answer is
no no I know the guy and I spoke to him
about it his name is am eliyahu Israel
has never caret bombed
any 1967 was preemptive he was asked a
question by a provocative interview and
he said well if you're going to bomb the
same thing like it was a Muhammed job
type you want to kill all the Arabs
three million people just drop a bomb he
said well if you want to drop a bomb
drop a bomb he was being dismissive and
stupid and he put out a statement the
next day saying that never in history
would the Jews ever eat even contemplate
doing that let's remember one thing the
only place in Middle East one second
only place the only place in in the
Middle East where Arabs have any
freedoms Israel the only place where
they vote openly Israel the only place
where Palestinian women can dress the
way they want Israel the only and let's
be clear when when when Muhammad hijab
gets up and says that we Palestinians
want to be a religion of death you know
I just got a haircut coming here by an
Arab Barber here in London and he said
to me I hope you I hope you defeat this
guy because he doesn't represent us we
want to live we want to have good lives
we want to be religious we want to eat
but we don't want to die from Mar you
are not a Muslim you're an Islam let me
ask Muhammad let me ask Muhammad a
question let me ask Muhammad a
question Hamas has
240 last week stop Hamas has 240
hostages they took including babies sure
young kids sure grandmothers who survive
the Holocaust I mean an unspeakable
further criminal act we can agree right
of course why should Israel agree to any
ceasefire so long as those hostages are
still being kept hostage look um my
position is very clear they should fight
man to man on the on the ground no that
fighting that's exactly what they're
doing that fighting no one can this is
that's exactly what they're doing manto
man they took hostages ex they took
babies as host he's ask me the question
infants as hostages let him answer the
question you're getting excited here I
know it's your sexuals are you're the
sex RAB now you're
back
he getting excited with me let me ask
the questions you guys answer them
Muhammad answer my question why if
you're Israel would you ever agree to a
ceasefire if those hostages aren't
released I'm I'm telling you what my
position is my position is man-to-man
combat which is what they're doing now
no that part of it is understandable do
you understand that's what they're doing
no problem but what I think is not
understandable what is not acceptable
because you said what's a proportional
response that's the question you keep
asking everybody my answer to you is a
proportionate response is one where in
which the ratios are not 100 to one on
that's your invention excuse me please
where does that come from your Source
tell me the source me
thece yeah sure when did they say it I
know all the IDF spces I know Jonathan I
Daniel haari said what when EXC say when
did he say we're
killing 10 days ago and it's mentioned
on a website I tell you truth is they
don't he never
said you ask
meite which ask Al jaaz no is it Al jaaz
you've asked me a question right okay
are you scared to hear the response go
ahead okay the response is as follows
the guardian the guardian has reported
that the IDF have said that in terms of
the numbers of Hamas that have been
killed I'm answering this question the
Hamas that have been killed they say
quote unquote dozens now listen H
civilian you said civilians you said
civilian I'm telling you where I got the
100 to1 ratio rtio the
numbers 10,000 civilians 60 is actually
more than soon as you call
he can hear what you're saying let me
respond to him this is a blood
Li have a right to respond BL it's a
blood liel here's the reality I read
that report that was about at least two
weeks ago right days the numbers have
changed a lot Israel now believe they've
killed a lot more Hamas we don't know
exactly how many cuz actually how do you
tell on the ground
way you know according to the IDF and
we've done a study on the name that they
put on X they have they had
1,280 names that they put on X and
according to they put is as he knows a
left wi newspaper in Israel they also
put the names of those who have been
killed guess what according to them 340
military have been killed which means
hamas's ratio of combatant to not
combatant is 3:1 imagine Hamas is doing
a better job in protecting civilians
than Israel 3 to1 vers I would say that
Hamas by what they did on October the
7th ver wait a minute wait a minute wait
a minute ordered by by doing what they
did they ordered de facto the
disintegration of Northern Gaza that
we're seeing of and all the
civilian death of thousands Civ they
knew what was going to happen age that's
why they should go 20 in 2005 Israel
unilaterally withdrew from Gaza and
allowed
well Hamas won an election 2006 they
could have built Singapore you know what
they did they took larger foreign aid
per capita than all of Europe received
from the Marshall Plan and look what
France and Britain look how beautiful
London is they took that money and they
bought bullets and bombs they did not
build hospitals not school they stole it
from the Palestinian people is hania is
worth4
billion I don't care about
woron call him call him evil
say he won't he will never condemn
because he has condemned I heard him do
it EXC he condemned hamas's attack he's
never condemned Hamas let me ask you do
you condemn Hamas on what basis here we
go see you accept now let let me ask let
me ask you a question every answer is on
one basis I want this this what's your
Source even if you ask me if you do
condemn IDF I say specify your context
in what exact cont do I do you defend
Hamas as a terrorist organization that
just went and killed 12200 people burned
them alive beheaded them and took 250
hostages do you condemn them or not do
you condemn them or not get your head
get your head into the debate and do you
condem or not see this is a this is a
debating two11 it's become two-on one
you're not a victim stop the victim now
it's two onone stop the victim you love
portraying yourself as a strong man now
you're a victim it's two onone you
probably could take two onone so answer
it answer the question is Hamas a terror
organization you can is that something h
a terror
organization it's a reasonable question
because you as me the IDF beautiful I'll
answer your question
directly Hamas is as much a terrorist
organization yet no Hamas shouldn't be
called a terrorist organization if if if
the IDF isn't why because either both
either both or neither nether to
extrapolate your position because you
believe the IDF is then you're also
saying that Hamas is let me tell you my
position say it say
it let R let me get the answer the UNH
won't let me speak right I'm asking
question the first rme did the whole
could be
friends given you've already stated you
believe the IDF is a terror organization
yeah yeah am I am I to assume you
believe legally or Mor hang on I much to
assume that you believe Hamas is now no
this is what this is my position but you
have to give me 10 seconds at least to
answer right legally I think you
shouldn't call Hamas a terrorist
organization if you're not calling IDF a
terrorist organization that's my
position do both call Terror hold on
hold hold on let me finish because if
the as we said the UN definition of what
a terrorist organization is to kill
civilians in order in order to achieve a
political objective however on a moral
and theological philosophical level I
agree with Rosalyn Higgins who was the
Justice of the international criminal
court right the court of justice icj a
British Jus by the way she was a
holocaust Survivor as well she was
Jewish yeah and her position is that she
believes that the word terrorism or
terrorist is actually useless and she
says that it's I'm putting to her can
you answer question he's going on to let
me finish so I'm answer your question so
I'm saying that as a moral construct I
think it's a neoc colonial social
construct used by people in order to to
label some people as terrorist other
people as so as a moral category I don't
designate it as a
moral as a legal category do you believe
do you personally Muhammad do you
believe that the IDF and Hamas are both
Terror organizations I think yes if if
you if you say if you say yes to IDF you
should say yes to Hamas you say no
to is a terrorist organization you
believe if you say yes to IDF you can
say yes to Hamas I'm ask you what you
believe yes I believe legally according
to the definition if you say yes to
Hamas you can say yes to idea we can go
on for the next I've got we are going
you say no to for the next F we're going
to we're going to the next we're going
to the next block uh but that's
interesting but morally I don't believe
the category has any weight no but you
has no designation but you have made
your position clear which is that you
believe they're both Terror
organizations I believe that according
to the law absolutely okay and that's
interesting to me okay's I have to say I
have wait let's come to when you call
the IDF a terror organization the IDF
keeps 1. million Arabs alive in Israel
Hamas this is invention it's a fabric
let me move on the last get more
pictures out it's unbelievable how you
loseing
I my son my son is like my son is in the
idea you're here in the safety of Studio
talking about how you want to do
martyrdom you're really risking your
life here Mom you you're big
talk you attack you attack you attack
Ben Shapiro's wife IDE you you actually
you actually posted a saying that with
someone else saying that aach you how to
get how to get women toist listen to
their
husbands false bravado false false moiso
if you're a real man go to the Middle
East and fight what are you doing in
a can we move to the last one which you
should be there you you have the right
to fight with use your son
human people in De and it's being
allowed I want to move to the last
ironically themed subject is peace
possible okay uh not on this basis right
but we've got to try and get to Peace So
you get a minute each again uh Muhammad
you'll go first this time so you get a
minute from now okay so I just wanted to
say that this man is conect no no is
peace POS ever possible I've got a
minute interrupted is peace ever
possible can I uninterrupted we got to
speak about the subject I can say what
he's been attacking me don't attack him
person we're not going to use it it's
pointless I'm going to take it just for
the record we'll put it on YouTube so
people can see it all in context right
but on my show I'm just not going to
have half of this what I thought was
going to be a serious debate taken up
with you two personally abusing each
other bisar excuse me Von bismar said I
repay people with the currency that they
pay me with if he's going to come
without homs as you've acknowledged I
can come back right but you did and you
shouldn't have done because you had the
high
moral other in both Asad mention that on
the personal stuff we've been as bad as
each other let's start again you get a
minute from now is peace ever possible
go Justice is a prerequisite for peace
in South Africa when the aparti system
which we know for a fact is is an AP
partite State because it has laws like
the right of return which only only only
allow Jewish people to come into the
country and if they convert by the way
to Christianity or to je to Islam they
are stripped from that right which is it
meets completely the definition of a
party that's po Coral law school and
according to the UN convention 1973 it's
an aparte system and as a prerequisite
of an aparte system you have to be a
racist if you support that you're racist
no doubt about it so number one 1973
apart law if the black South Africans
have been displaced if they have been
displaced by the whites and then they
were try to come back into their country
and they were not allowed and then you
ask them as peace possible that's not
the question we would be asking them
we'll be asking them as just as possible
and that's the question that we're going
to be asking because he can all sit
there and talk about all these things
where the IDF his son Mendy is being
attacked by vibrated by the the rockets
and he's selling him and his daugh
selling vibrat to the
public unnecessary thing at the end
again I hope you keep that in one minute
on is peace ever possible of course I
countries like the United Arab Emirates
Dubai Abu Dhabi where I've spoken
several times I am safer as a Jew
wearing a yamaka in Dubai and Abu Dhabi
than I am on the campus of Columbia
University or even Harvard these days
the Muhammad bin bin zad is just an
incredible leader um I saw in the Gulf
States the Islam that Muhammad hijab
rejects but the Islamic World Embraces
that's why they made peace with Israel
it's a technologically advanced tolerant
forward-looking very traditional very
religious Islam and that's and that's
why and that's why they've made peace
with Israel and peace will continue to
be made all of these countries are
praying for Israel to destroy Hamas
because Muhammad isab is an outlier he's
an extremist and his views whether his
views as he represents them at Speaker's
Corner of things about women being
subject let me just let me just be
clear all of the Arab countries want
Kamas destroyed and that's and the proof
is when they had their conference Riyad
last week they did not even once call to
bring in any evacuees cuz they want
Israel to establish a more democratic
regime in Gaza which will they will do
is follow to both of you right just give
me a very very quick snapshot of in 20
years time how peace could have been
achieved very quickly okay the first
thing is when Israel withdrew in 2005
almost 20 years ago um if Hamas had not
come to power if they had taken all the
international Aid that they got um tens
of billions of dollars peace would have
been achieved by building businesses
Entre how do we get okay we get there
now by destroying Hamas making sure that
there's Democratic elections let the
Palestinian people
mam when you both agree Hamad should be
gone right we can agree on this right we
agre that there should be a bigger
Palestinian Authority
withies the way and the way we and the
way we have peace tank in the history of
the world no two Democratic and Rockets
uh Powers have ever gone to war that's
why since the end of the second world
war there's been no war here in Europe
we need to see a democratic Gaza
Kamas won an election 2006 war in Europe
now by the way cor because it's against
the Tyranny no I said no two democracies
ever gone to war Putin is not a
democracy he's a tyrant in the history
of the world no two democracies ever
fought a war we have a democracy in Gaza
what do peace look like in 20 years
peace looks like the Arabs voting for
their rulers voting and backing them
seeing Israel as a partner not being
humiliated that because of this tiny
little red dot surround humiliation St
solution I well you
know I'll tell you I'll tell you I'll
tell I'll tell you if if if two-state
solution is aamas State wanting to
eviscerate Israel he doesn't believe in
it but he doesn't believe in a two State
solution he believes in a Final Solution
that's really scares me you don't
believe in a solution believe in a final
solution way you speak about Jew you
believe
in do you believe in a two if that
second state is
Mexico if that second state is is is
Gaza then of course not because it'll
just become another genocidal enemy
wanting to wipe Israel off the map
that's pretty unequivocal he doesn't
really want a two-state solution I don't
want a two- State Solution that's a
that's that's a terrorist state to
destroy is personally believe this whole
question should be left to the
Palestinians or what kind of solution
they want however having said that this
man has written in his book a war in
Israel that is the settlement write a
book called a war it's called the the
Israel Warrior something like that thank
you thanks for plugging fantastic I
appreciate fantastic in that book he
writes that the issue of excuse me the
issue of settlements that me and you
both condemn peers I do yeah yeah yeah
we do he doesn't condemn it because he
sees a an ancient biblical reason to be
in that whole land I think is I think
Arabs in Israel should be able to live
wherever they want I want Arabs to live
in Jerusalem I want Arabs to live in T I
want Jews to live there I don't believe
in the ud Israel I don't believe in Arab
I am so proud that Israel has 1.8
million Arab Muslim citizens who are
protected by the idea he calls the IDE a
terrorist
defending what you should be less proud
of is the rapid expansion of these
settlements on the West Bank it has been
incredibly youn that been in my view
illegal it's been declared
illegal
many there are many things I'll defend
Israel about that is indefensive let me
let me answer if you go to places in
Judean samarra in the West Bank call
like because those are the Biblical land
who cares why do you call something
Arabia it's the
Arab you don't know history it was
always your day and Samar the West Bank
is the West Bank of a river we don't
call CIA the West Bank of mississipp
now let me go back let me go back let me
go back if you go to the Baran
industrial park in judan Sam you will
see I've met the Palestinians I've
interviewed them they are paid 20 times
the salary working for people you call
settlers they want them there it brings
civilization it's only jihadis who it's
only jihadis and that's why you're
saying yes it is true I've interviewed
many many
Palestinians
definely want live under with no
democracy come to afraid to criticize
jail my friend mam go ahead
mation you're wearing my favorite blue
color of course I'll let you fantastic
for that reason brilliant thank you just
because uh I'm wearing the blue my
mother loved that color and
she I thought it would have been because
of Israel because you oh that's right
you wore the Israeli car
today can you shake hands no please I
don't want to cuz your hands are shaking
your hands are sh sorry I mean look how
it's peaceful you would shake my hands
no I'll shake hands with you you would
Shake after what you said today about me
I can't shake your hand after what you
said about my sex life and I'm shaking
your hand stop stop I just want to say
you won't shake my hand you won't shake
my
head I guess it will be no you know you
know what he said there is a little bit
telling because you know the blue colors
and Israel and that kind of stuff he
defended dtz which was Jeffrey Epstein's
uh lawyer for that very reason because
he's a support of Israel I defended D
did D when I fought over him going toar
you don't know
anything abismal
me and Alan d had a huge fight over
defending qar who come on guys back to
did go
muhamad
years
years I know not going to use the stuff
about forget it what is your obsession
with sex I don't get it going to use any
both of you seem totally obsessable well
I wrote a book called coer sex for
marriages I didn't write it to get into
other people's bedroom I don't care
about either of your sex lives okay he
seems in M 20 years time I'm not 20
years time what does a potential piece
look like I don't know but is that's
that's a speculative question to be
honest you asking me a hypothetical you
I don't know you're asking me
hypothetical question I asked you a
hypothetical you said I don't do
hypotheticals want to give me hope why
did you don't answer my hypothetical
question if you're asking me question
the Belfast question why huh remember I
ask you the Belfast question and you
didn't answer it I don't think there is
the only parallel why you that because
they're different situations no but it's
hypothetical you're asking me
hypothetical now why you have to ask I'm
just asking you no but why do you have a
d think asking you how peace might look
like is hypothetical no it's talking
about the Future hypothe Would You me
let me rephrase it how would you like it
to be resolved this crisis okay
fantastic okay okay look yes let's look
at history R to the Sea that's how you
want it right no is let him answer don't
answer for him honestly you'll be
surprised to to know this and people
talk about you you said this I have to
correct you I looked at the Hamas chart
Hamas themselves yeah in in article 16
even they say you can have in article 31
they say that you can have peace between
they can have a shared land between
Christians Muslims and Jews they even
say that I I think the most radical
elements everybody you want the jihadis
these one that one no one actually wants
the extermination of Jewish people
that's that's a lie actually that's not
true Kamas wait wait wait let me let
meas Charter you know let me speak Kamas
Charter calls for the Kamas Charter says
that behind every single tree and stone
where a Jew now you're saying that the
it says that every Jew has to be
murdered how can possibly deny that you
know you have what say what does says in
the end of it's an eschatological it's
an esic which says that on the end of
times there will be a war and there will
be trees and stones that say behind me
is a is a Jew killing so Muhammad is
saying that the Jew this is a Hadith
which has been miss do what does it mean
what does it mean it means that it's
anical it's not an imperative do it mean
it's not an imperative are you o
according you're not okay tell
picko pick and Sho excuse me let me ask
you a question let me ask you a question
is this a theological question so I'm
answering you this Hadith is called an
esic you know this because you're a
theologian it's an eschatological Hadith
it's not talking about Lal it's not imp
it's not like 1 Samuel chapter 15 verse
number three where it says Go and Kill
the men women children donkeys and oxen
which by the way Netanyahu quoted he
quoted kill it's not like that see this
this is this is the blood liable of
saying the Jews want
to but
let me put a point to going to put a
point to I tell you who wants the
absolute annihilation of every Jew they
can get their hands on all the Hamas
terrorists who crossed the border on
October 7th who gleefully recorded it
boasted about it and the Hamas offic
wait a minute and the Hamas official
spokesman who only last week said they
want to do it again and again again if
you don't
think are wedded as an organization to
people you are
living in their it says that will
Mur that I agree with hold on let me
tell you I agree or disagree both the
IDF and Hamas on paper say they don't
want the annihilation of Muslims in
Jew says that's not I'm not Charter says
explicitly that every Jew will be
murdered by they are a
genocidal you are lying
sorry nobody can hear either of you the
point is in my estimation after October
the 7th Mass are now openly boastful
genocidal terrorist calling their
parents saying I killed I just said that
I just said the luced party in 1999 had
a charter and in it they said they want
the whole of Israel including as he
believes um the West Bank and Gaza and
everything if we are going to because
there they say they would kill Arab
government be equal citizens let me
finish let me finish they're not equal
because there's apar laws there's no
apar law the AP so let me explain that
no let me you can go to Portugal and
Spain and show that if you have ancestry
they give you citizenship that's Israel
if you Jewish no every listen this is
the country Arabs or not Muhammad
Muhammad let me speak let me speak we
live in a we live in a Christian country
Who The Sovereign head of state is a
Christian I'm a Jew I never felt
alienated from the fact that this is a
Christian country Arabs liers equal
citizens
je you know wait a minute I'm going to
the astonishing thing ask each other
question mam Muhammad had two Jewish
wies but you won't shake the hand of a
Jew and you know why that's not Islam
that's islamism islamism is is sub sad
we're going to the final part the final
part is where I want to try and end this
right it's been acrimonious it's been
passionate uh I'm not sure we've
achieved very much certainly not as much
as I hoped to um I think we're all
agreed that Hamas need to go um many
would perhaps agree net and Yahoo should
also have to go he doesn't he's his
friend right well I I personally think
the the will of the Israeli people
democratically elected leader I believe
in Hamas is a dictatorship they ended
elections a year after they a
dictatorship that's why mmud abas will
not go there he's afraid of them let me
finish just these fraulen
be challenged we're coming to the final
block this final block doesn't have a
thing I just want to see if we can get
to any points of agreement right we've
had all the arguments you've shattered
each other you've personally abused each
other yes right you're passionate you've
raised some good points but they've been
mostly shouted out I just want to know
how he his son comes back in a black you
sh us some pictures right such a
disgusting by way how would you like it
mam like it as much as thect my son you
know how low that you get you wife
you're not a real man real men don't
attack women real men don't tell us that
5y- old girls can have sex real men
don't speak about another yes you did on
my Instagram don't say that 5year old
girl prepubescent should have sex you
are talking about my son cuz you're not
a real man why if you really believe you
really believe why your you would not be
in the safety
of of a studio in London not bring up my
son do not bring
upo stop picking on women stop see you
you want you want debate but imagine man
saying that your son your son is
dead morality you have no decency you
have no and this is because this man is
here I can SP speak about my sex life
he's here to say my son's going to die
he is a Jew hater he's an anti-semite
he's an islamist and the fact that this
debate has gone along this way allowing
every question come from
European
my father's from Iran my friend you know
nothing
about my father's from Iran my father
was raised around Muslim he didn't meet
Muslims
like fact the fact that he's been
allowed to offer Fabrications of Jews
killing mil people the fact that he's
allowed to offer Fabrications that that
have no source that the idea is killing
a thousand to one the fact that he's
been allowed to tell his lies is a
travesty of this show it's a travesty of
the media the fact that he has not been
challenged by you is
unacceptable every question fact that
he's allowed to talk about my sex life
sex life he's obsessed with people's sex
life this is a travesty and the fact
that you're not
ashamed the fact that you are not
ashamed how you humiliate Islam Islam is
a great
world and Muslims should reject this not
me Muslims this it would be a lot easier
for me to challenge him which I have
done repeatedly and actually EV
his if you allowed me to do my job ra
shout over one he was interviewing you
pierce from the first second he was
asking you question no I wasn't he was
asking me a perfect he was asking me a
perfectly legitimate question which I
was trying to answer but you kept
shouting as you have done for the for
the entire show this is not not a debate
a debate that talks about my sex life
tax women says my children are this is
not a
debate this is a man who cannot debate
he has to bring why don't you make
arguments of showing pictures drama to
show these
pictures why don't you care about
Muslims being killed by Hamas the 17
years stealing their money bother you
that ish is worth4
billion should we do you want to even
conclude this because it's pointless
it's not me I speaking I mean in a way
what what you what do either of you
think you've achieved with
this constant person I'll answer that
I'll answer I'll constant personal abuse
I'll answer I'll answer I'll answer can
I answer that question I'll I'll tell
you what I've
achieved people like islamists like
Muhammad hijab and you can if you don't
interrupt me I'll finish with this and
then you can speak they believe that
Israel is going to disappear they
believe that we Jews are afraid of them
they believe that we Jews won't debate
them they believe that we tremble he had
he did a video last week when he said
did you see how they tremble I have seen
who are they who are they I say Jews who
did who then who did you mean so why did
you who did you mean me the Jews he
won't even say antisemitism C you know
why I'm here you know why I'm here let
me finish ant you know why I'm here
antism you know why I'm here I'm here to
show to shut the debate down cuz you're
weak weak just like your son son
the down the baboni we have
star come back star down the Greeks we
will stare down mammad and F we are the
Eternal Nation so I you know I've
achieved I've shown people like him that
we are going nowhere we're not afraid of
them we don't tremble We're Not Afraid
and if we haven't achieved the
constructive dialogue we've tried with
the Palestinians for 75 years we offered
them a two-state solution 1936 I don't
think you've made any attempt to
civilize come on this was never
civilized from the first okay this
civilized can I just this was never
civilized man accusing Israel of killing
3 million Palestinians is a lie Man Who
Cannot side sources is Li he's saying's
saying he's saying that Israel is an a
to this of course 20% 20% of the what
you say black by the way what do you
want to say they're black and if you
look at the hars newspapers they're
treated as second class citizens uh what
do you want to say in conclusion hold on
I want to say something that he said
about the peel report in 1936 which is a
point of historical contention he
doesn't know that he mentions this in
his book as well he's mentioned it
before seven times that the Palestinian
one in peace he doesn't know what
history is because let me respond to you
in 1936 and 1937 where the pill report
happened under the Premiership of Ramsey
McDonald and then 1939 when the white
paper took place under the Premiership
of Neville Chamberlain actually the Arab
High committee which represented the
voice of the Palestinian people agreed
with the conclusions of the peel report
in 1947 the Arab League agreed with the
conclusions of the peel report he
doesn't know that because there's no
truth to that I'll give the Jem excuse
me excuse me I'll give you the sources I
all he said we will never accept it and
then he moved to Germany and lived ADF
Hitler that's the truth the M of
Jerusalem give the let pure fraudulence
it's not true the Jerusalem was a Nazi
and he rejected it and they all
he was a na correct he he was a na was a
na he was Nazi he shook hands with
Hitler no he went to live with
Hitler I don't know if he you know is
all completely unwatchable people are
home and just go what is the matter with
these two
guys want my nation
to why can't you try and have some
civilized dialogue no because I'm
answering his questions but let him me
speak neither of you can okay so here's
what I'm saying I'm not interrupting him
I'm saying you didn't interrupt me V
done to each other the entire show okay
here's what I'm saying in 1936 1937 you
have the pill he said what's the source
the source is the pales the Encyclopedia
of Palestine so the sources the cable
gram which you can find on the UN
website in 1947 that on the I tell you
the days on the 15th of May
1948 which is when one day after the
state of Israel was established
according to the UN website which you
can find the public a primary source
material that the Arab leak said that we
consider the conclusions of the peel
report as acceptable and the 1948 they
said that five Arab Nations invaded
Israel next day Independence 1% entire
Israeli population were murdered by the
Arab armies did you just say they
accepted the state of Israel did you
really just say I just say that I said
said that in 1948 the Arabs accepted the
state of is I'm giv you sources I'm
giving you does this show up any
credibility let give you sources you
just answered it can I can I give you
sources that's what you're there for the
the sources that I'm presenting the
sources that I'm presenting you is as
yes you're right of course there was a
war in 194 five Arab Nations five Arab
Nations only three of them cross the
border according to Rashid in his book
100y Year War which which I can
recommend to you and other books as well
Albert her and others secondary source
material but the primary source material
is this in
1947 there undoubtedly it's it's on the
UN website you can find that the Arab
League they accepted the conclusions of
the peal commission that took place 1936
years later no 1940 19 1940 what about
me giving you an example this is all
getting the we let me take you to to the
mid90s right the mid90s there was a
deal3 which was the proper deal right
and Arafat at the last minute walked
away SCE well the source is Bill Clinton
who' done the deal with the source is
Dennis Ross and let me no Bill Clinton
says in his Memoirs my life I told that
you made me a failure agreed the deal
with Bill Clinton and then Rene on the
deal can looking back it's not wrong can
I can I it's not wrong Mohammad and
looking back and looking back to respond
let me finish my question to you and
looking back on it I would simply say
yeah when you look at the entire history
of this conflict let me respond to that
please yeah let that was the moment when
real peace could have been achieved
that's wrong let me tell you why okay
let me tell you why and you can both
listen to this very carefully and take
notes and check me fact check me answer
the question no go ahead and fact check
me in 1993 you have the ow Accords both
there was two signaries as you knowa and
Rabin and both of them got the peace
price for that you know that one knows
that except pardon Paris of course but
I'm saying the two the Prime Minister
and and the time they signed it you
agree yes you WR in your book up until
2000 there were what you call Peace
conferences that took place taba one
taba 2 etc etc you agree everyone agrees
all right in 2000 this is what you're
talking about not 93 cuz 93 arat 93 was
also one 95 was also he's
talking arat Bill Clinton the
per David correct whole period when arat
and Clinton yes we're negotiating and
they finally got to a point he's right
he's he's saying that he's right because
he's saying that in 2000 the Camp David
correct excellent now you see from 1993
up until 2000 you had these peace
conferences everyone agrees okay in 2000
and the Y River records which is by
nanyu by the way the he was against the
whole thing he signed the White River
let me come let me come to you 2000 is
what you're talking about walking let me
tell you some sources I'll give you
Israeli Source because I know Dennis
Ross is what you call it he's he's a
bias Source right-winged uh Zionist
whatever I'll give you another Zion
Source his name is uh uh what his name
is bin he's been B Ami Ben Ben Amy
mentioned Ben Amy mentioned that the the
de the deal that was struck in 2000 he
wouldn't accept it himself if he was a
Palestinian that's what he said in his
words in his Memoirs number one number
two is if you consider what happened I
don't know armi is he seems to be the
most check out Google it he could be
aant he was let me let me please you
know what it doesn't matter it does
matter cuz you're saying they walked
away it's not read Bill Clinton's
biography he's getting from he's getting
it from he was there I believe Bill
Clinton no no he's getting let me just
be clear Bill Clinton and a Barack
offered
97% of the West Bank Sam wa wait wait
wait and and and not only did AR not
accept the deal Arafat didn't even
counter he left without countering and
then when arat was leaving and he shook
Bill Clinton's hand this is the story
that Bill Clinton tells in his book my
life shook his hand and he said Mr
Clinton you're a great man and then
Clinton looked him in the eye and said
I'm not a great man I'm a failure and
you have made me one you go going to one
no no wait wait but then let's get it
gets better it gets
better it was widely
reported get
better in 2008 you're wrong Muhammad how
am I wrong give me
your is the president of United States
he's biased
like away from the
best the whole let me
explain do you resp you for magazine you
believe for
magazine died can we make make it maybe
maybe L the are you scared are you
scared of my response uh I don't think
so you use the word scared a
lotun respond okay run away from Don't
Run Away 199 I'm right here okay
great stop shouting Rabbi 93 as as we
said there was all these Accords from 93
to 200000 now in 19 what was what were
the contentions let me tell you what the
contentions were in ooso CS number one
Jerusalem number two the settlements
number three the occupied territories
number before the borders that's what
they were mentioning yeah you forgot the
you forgot the refugees the most
contentious refug for completely the
refugees correct which is the right to
return law and we know this apar anyway
but anyways it's not apar every every
country in Europe allows people with
ancestry you have a point M okay I do
have a point which is as follows they
divided the areas into area a b and c
okay that was a 2 95 corre sure so what
I'm saying is in that time the question
is who was treacherous to the agreement
because we know that as you know you
condemned the settlements that was part
of the osow cords no no the people was
arat who was giving the terrorist money
to kill Jews a thousand Jews di which is
the equivalent here in Britain of 30,000
people being killed in Terror attacks
all right can I can I ask can I ask m
one question please you said also one
also two may I ask you one question I
don't know if I want to tell question
well you you don't have to answer but so
this is the point how much how much how
much of the Palestinian population in
the West Bank as you call it is
controlled right now by the Palestinian
Authority what percentage of the
Palestinians are under are under you
won't answer it you don't know do you
none of it because all of
it how many are control
to
here what we're going
do7 you know what it's like I'm going to
end the show by you both having a minute
un interrupted sure to summarize right
let go first there's no problem how you
think we move on from here because
clearly anyone watching this is going to
see two completely intractable sides
right this is what I see on Twitter all
day long right I see people on the
Israeli side and on the prop Palestinian
side and they scream at each other all
day long right they say something that
are right some whatever there's get you
involved in it well you both said to me
before we sat down I don't want to speak
abve himself speak out the term but you
both said to me independently the two of
us ging up in him finally well you both
said to me before we started you said
that the American uh Jewish Community
were very pleased with what I done on
this show and you said that the Muslim
World pleased done on the show and I
took that as a perfect extrapolation of
what we've been trying to achieve which
is giving both sides a voice and a PL I
my minute what has not worked what has
not worked is bringing you together like
this because actually it's been a an ear
thumping screaming match so you're now
going to get a minute each to to
summarize right and in the summary I
want to see if we can at least pretend
to be constructive here right because
the world needs this somehow to end okay
so RAB you go first first of all
Muhammad thank you very much for wearing
the Israeli colors thank you for your
support of the Georgia state we great
appreciate it I should have done the
same secondly uh I I'm sorry you
wouldn't shake my hand I will shake your
hand anytime because I do believe what
Pierce said we have to have peace and
Harmony going forward it's a shame that
you said no
third peace will come my Arab brothers
and sisters who are the green on this
map except that tiny little thing that
I'm covering with my finger that tiny
little thing called Israel and when they
understand that Israel is not the Jewish
homeland Israel is actually the great
Arab hope if our Arab brothers and
sisters get the economic prosperity of
Israel the rights for women the rights
for freedom of freedom of assembly to
criticize their governments without fear
the way the people in Hamas in Gaza
would be murdered by Hamas let alone in
uh Palestinian Authority they'd be
thrown in jails Israel is the great hope
let me just say this Islam is a great
world religion it created the world's
first universities it introduced
agricultural reforms in Europe under
Sultan Akbar in India 400 years before
Europe you had um you had Al Razzi who
introduced medical reforms 600 years
before the the and if we return to that
kind of Advance not the Islam that is
being advocated by Muhammed which is
Antiquated and ages then we will have
peace so God bless my Muslim brothers
and sister and I will shake your hand
anytime Muhammad a minute for you as I
said before and I'll say it again
Justice is a prerequisite for peace if
this was the case that it was South
Africa and both Nations had a long and
known history with each other Israel and
South Africa there's a book called The
Secret Alliance that you can read for
your further information if this was
South Africa and the blacks were kicked
out of their country they they were
kicked out of their country by the
whites like the nakba
700,000 Palestinians were kicked out and
then they had the audacity to talk about
peace nobody would be accepting it the
apartheid laws of South Africa are the
same effectively as the apartheid laws
of Israel you're not allowed to come
back to the country unless you are of a
specific ethnicity which meets the
requirement for aparte they 100 to1
ratio of being killed in Gaza this seems
to be acceptable to Sho un holy it's
speak to be acceptable to him it's not
acceptable it's not acceptable to me
it's not acceptable to the people when
we see these images it's absolutely not
acceptable so peace is justce
requirement for Peace by the
way you don't get to go all over doesn't
matter what your name look I found that
quite a dispiriting hour I've got to be
honest with you doesn't matter I thought
both of you let yourselves down I gave
you a great opportunity here we gave you
players come on well fine you can you
like we gave you an audience you gave us
an audience care it's fine it's not just
about the audience it's about a big
audience which we're getting for all
these shows about a big audience seeing
people try to come nobody here has seen
you try even try to come together you're
notp spirting to me what can I do with
all your respects since try hard you
know I believe I believe I believe in
Mand Nelson Mandela could have gone down
this Ro when he came out of prison after
27 years and they called him a terrorist
they called him a terrorist wait a
minute
he could have come out of prison and he
could have taken the path of Vengeance
in he was violent instead talk he took
the path of Peace he wasent he took
the when he came out of prison he took
the path of peace
violist terorist I take constructive and
I will think about what you said Mandela
was but I will tell you he was
against but I will tell you I will tell
you if you bring two people on to a
debate and you're saying that we let you
audence don't give L don't give him
loning successful you Su and you and you
allow I'll be quiet man one one one to
bring up don't give him lesson stuff
that is so just embarrassing like sex
people's sex
lives did not no I did not I oh I'm
proud of my books on sex but this is a
debate about don't care about your sex
lives either of you all right seem to be
really interested for me whatever we'll
talk later keep it on sensor good
night